new york city
how do you shine when there are 8
million people also striving for the
spotlight
how do you make it what others fall to
is it luck
hard work determination that brings you
the fame you see
maybe all the above but this isn't my
story
it's called anthony's
[Music]
the highest touted prospect in the
country
[Music]
no matter how bad things go he has
supreme confidence the most competitive
player this
nba draft he has high steel potential
and i think that he's nba ready can run
a team
right now he can be dynamite
at times
[Music]
for the crown right here basketball in
new york is a different animal man
basketball is in this city's soul it's
on every corner and in every part
there's been so many legendary players
that came from these streets
it's a badger honor to be a baller from
new york
playing basketball in new york is kind
of a way of life
there's not a lot of gyms in new york
city but there's a lot of basketball
courts
so everyone plays the game right here
you're born into it it's what you do
regardless of your background where your
parents come from
um
there's eight million people there so
how do you differentiate yourself from
eight million people
you know you have to be special you have
to be loud
in doing it at times
i think cole anthony is new york
basketball
new york oops he here's what you think
when you think of a new york player
gritty top assertive
[Music]
grimy he is new york basketball in that
sense he is
your typical new york city
one redeeming quality all of us have is
that we're all tough i mean
you're not going to find no guards from
new york that play dead and just let
someone walk all over them they're going
they're going to give it they all no
matter what who it is
a new york legend doesn't just appear
now our new york legend is built
and for cole anthony his journey began
before he came to be
as the son of nba player and new york
knick
greg anthony has been one of the unsung
heroes what a performance
it was always cool to have that dad and
it was not until i was older i really
learned to appreciate
i mean my dad being a former nba player
being someone who had been through the
process that i want to be through
he was born in 2000
so he never ever saw me play you know he
obviously would know
because people would say something about
it but for him he just always played
because he loved it i woke up this
morning
inspired my mom has this picture of me
when i think i was like six months old
like before i could walk
just throwing a basketball as a who i
just always had that dream when i was
younger i mean i wasn't even thinking
about how good i was i was just thinking
that i wanted to be an nba
don't let them take your soul away come
on towards the end of the fifth grade
uh you know he was playing baseball and
i'm a big baseball fan
and he came to me after game and never
forget it he was like dad you know i
just wanted to tell you uh
i don't want to play baseball anymore i
just want to focus on basketball
and it caught me off guard quite frankly
one
you know he wasn't that good at
basketball at the time
i wasn't even aware that i was that bad
but i mean my friends tell you it wasn't
that good
but i mean it's just i always just had
love for the sport
he would compete like crazy but his
skill set
i i didn't envision him as necessarily
developing into what he's developing
into
[Music]
i was born i was just
focused on being the best individual
player i can be i wasn't really worried
about
following footsteps to anyone not even
my dad just my own person i want to
do everything i can for myself
body started to grow a little bit he
started to get a little more athletic
skill set was starting to develop the
better he got
the better he wanted to get so when he
started to get some national recognition
it kind of fueled his fire
and it made him work harder
[Music]
he would always want to do things better
than i did them at certain stages
so he you know he's like dad was the
first time you dumped
and i said well in ninth grade you know
it was the first time he said well you
know
i want to be able to dunk in eighth
grade
i think i've become my own player i
don't think i laid on my dad's name
anymore i think i've created my own name
it's hard to come up in this city but
once you do
damn the light shines bright
cole went to archbishop malloy with some
of the most legendary new york players
bald in high school and the hype just
exploded
[Music]
the fall of 2015 you know rumblings
around the city you know
you know people start to talk there's
this freshman out in arbitration malloy
that as a freshman is starting on the
varsity squad so first and foremost
in new york city the chsa which is the
catholic league takes pride of being one
of the toughest leagues
in the country you don't play as a
freshman of varsity squad period
very very rare it doesn't happen well
lawyers have you know they've had kenny
smith
you know kenny anderson and russ smith
they've had some guards come out of
there
but no one has been able to come in
right off the bat and just start day one
cole anthony what a finish paul anthony
so by the time junior year comes around
cole worked his way all the way up to be
the number one point guard in the
country
that's essentially how we came upon
deciding half you know it was time for
coal to be on slam cover
cool look at me there you go we were
trying to figure out who when was the
last time
that the number one point guard in the
country
was based in new york in new york city
and we said oh shoot the last time that
happened was like you know 20 plus years
ago
it was stefan marbury 1995.
so it became this historic thing
i remember on the cover we put like
prince of new york or something like
that and then like two months later he
leaves new york to go to virginia to
finish his high school career
and you know a lot of people were like
you know why is he leaving you know why
is he
why is he staying i've been having this
status in new york for oak hill
definitely caught a lot of people off
guard
because see new york isn't used to being
sean but they couldn't see his vision
was set on something great
the reason i did that was just because i
felt like just there wasn't much
left for me in new york just in terms of
basketball i felt that
i want to play in a more competitive
league played with uh dudes that were
better
so we felt that going okay was the best
choice
cole just needed some maturity he had
never been to oak hill until we dropped
him off
and i remember he told me you know dad
or whatever you say
i'm going to trust you that's a beauty
from cole anthony
number one guard in the country it was a
challenge especially
how he had grown up the way he had grown
up but it did
really help him mature and become a man
anthony getting past his man anthony
with the windmill slam
showcasing the flight locked away by a
lob for anthony
is right there
i think that's part of the story as well
right is that you know he
becomes the top dog here in new york
then by senior year he makes a decision
of like i have to do what's best for me
and maybe a lot of people in new york
didn't you know felt some type of way
that he left et cetera
but that was definitely what was best
for him oak hill is iconic
and with coal at the helm scouts from
all over klamath to get a glimpse and
the office rolled in
for him the choice was obvious
he knew it had to be somewhere legendary
i really want to thank all the schools
that recruited me
i mean i had my final four but at the
end of the day
we end up going with north carolina
north carolina
cole seemed destined for greatness but
he had no idea the next step would be
the most challenging chapter of his life